and some precalculus techniques starting
to get you introduced into calculus but
there's some shortcuts once you get to
calculus to do this much quicker so
we're kind of doing it the longer
version way in this video so the first
thing we're going to just kind of go
over are these formulas the summation
formulas we're going to use in the
problem that were going to do here
together
so what this shows you is that the sum
of a constant will be the constant times
n meaning like how many of those you
have so if you're adding up let's say
210 times like it's just going to be 2
times 10 which is 20 and then here this
is the sum of consecutive integers so
you would take however many integers you
have let's say 1 through 10 you have 10
integers would be 10 times 11 divided by
2 so if you added all those numbers up
and then the sum of squares and the sum
of cubes so we're gonna be using these
summation formulas but the next thing
we're gonna take a look at it's this
area formula over here on the right
so in order to find the area what we're
gonna do is we're going to subdivide a
region into rectangles okay and by
finding the area of each one of those
rectangles and then summing them okay
adding them all up we can find the area
of a region okay now what's interesting
is is that the smaller the thinner that
the rectangles are the more accurate the
area estimation becomes until you take
the limit to infinity meaning that the
rectangles are infinitely thin you're
going to get the exact area underneath
the curve okay so I'm just have a little
sample over here sometimes this is
called the right rectangular
approximation method or that rram okay
but what we're going to do is we're
going to find the area underneath this
curve right here between a and B so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
figure out well how many rectangles we
want to use to divide up this region
well if we take this distance which is B
minus a okay and let's just say so B
minus a let's say we want to divide it
up into like just two rectangles so like
this okay so then you can see the width
of each rectangle would be B minus a
divided by two right but if we wanted to
divide it up into four rectangles
see if you can divide this here better
like this then you can see that the
error is going to be a little bit more
accurate because you're not going to
have as much of a you know under
estimation or over estimation but what
you're going to do is going to take this
wif B minus a and you're going to divide
it by n and is the number of rectangles
that you're using so that's going to
give you the width of each of these
individual rectangles so we're just
finding from here to here okay so that's
the width B minus a divided by n now
what this represents here is the height
of each rectangle so when you find the
area of a rectangle it's the width of
the rectangle times the height right or
the base times the height we're going to
just say width times height so we're
going to start over here at a so this is
a or 8 right here and then what we're
going to do is we're going to go to the
right B minus a over N so that's one
whiff okay we're gonna go one whiff to
the right okay and then what we're gonna
do is we're going to take that x value
okay and we're gonna put it into our
function okay this is our function right
here and you're going to get the output
which is the Y value which is the height
of the rectangle but you can see what
we're doing is we're actually finding
the height here on the right side of the
rectangle not the left side okay so
that's just an important distinction and
that distinction doesn't really matter
as much as you go towards infinity
because the rectangles are gonna become
infinitely small you're gonna get the
exact area you know whether you use the
right rectangular approximation method
or the left one or the middle one okay
but for this example we're just gonna
use the right one and then you can see
this little variable here I okay it's
like an index so basically you know as
you go I equals one you're gonna find
the height of this rectangle here when
you go I equals two you're gonna find
the height of this rectangle here I
equals three and then I equals four if
you have four rectangles so the key
thing is that you're starting at the
left okay side of the area that you want
to find and you just keep adding one
width then that you find the height at
that point then you add another width
you find the height at that point okay
so you're with me so far so let's go
ahead and do this in an example and
you'll see how this works so say for
example we want to find the area
underneath this curve y equals x squared
plus 1 from 0 to 2 so from 0
I've shaded it in right there we want to
find that area now it's not so easy to
find this area because of this curve
portion it's not like it's a trapezoid
or you know a triangle or rectangle so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use this way of dividing up the region
into rectangles and we're going to find
the limit as n approaches infinity
meaning these rectangles are getting
thinner and thinner to find the exact
area okay so you're with me so far okay
so let's do that so we're gonna use this
formula right over here so first things
first we have B minus a okay which is
2-0 okay a is over here is 0 and B is
over here too
so a 2-0 divided by and so that's 2
divided by ad okay so that's this over
here that's the width of each rectangle
okay so let's write that down
2 over n okay then we've got F of a okay
which in this case a is 0 plus B minus a
divided by n so that's 2 minus 0 which
is 2 divided by n times I okay and there
you go so this is going to represent the
x-coordinate when we put it into the
function that's going to give us the y
coordinate or the height of our
rectangle then we're going to multiply
by the width of our rectangle so just
for example like this if we do two
rectangles so this would be the width
here and then this would be the height
okay so now all we have to do is we just
have to substitute this in so let's see
what we can do here so I equals 1 to N
so we're gonna put 2 divided by n I this
is our input we're gonna put that in for
X on the right so that's 2i over N
squared plus 1 times 2 over N okay we're
going to find the sum from I equals 1 to
ad if we simplify this what do we get we
get 4 I squared divided by N squared
plus 1 times 2 divided by n okay and
then if we distribute what do we get we
get 8 I squared divided by n cubed plus
2 over N okay still summing those up now
what you can do at this point is you can
actually split these up into two
summation so let's do that here we're
going to substitute this I split this up
into eight I squared over n cubed plus
the sum of two divided by n so you can
split this up into two summations then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
bring this part here in front of the
summation this is a constant and it's
just a the number of rectangles that
we're using same thing over here I'm
going to bring this one over N in front
okay since that's just a constant so we
have eight over N cubed times the sum of
I squared plus 1 over N times 2 okay so
now if we go to our summation form is
the sum of consecutive squares is this
right here so I'm going to substitute
that in let's let's go down here so
we've got 8 over n cubed I squared is
going to give us what it's n times n
plus 1 times 2n plus 1 all divided by 6
plus 1 over N times ok now the sum of a
constant ok n times is just the constant
times n so in this case this is just
going to be times 2n and you can see the
ends are going to cancel so we just get
2 for that let's go ahead and do some
simplification here if we foil this out
we get 2 N squared times ad which gives
you 2 and cubed we get 2 n plus 1 n is 3
n times n is 3 and squared 1 times 1 is
1 times n is n okay all divided by 6 now
the 6 and the 8 I'm going to reduce so
this is going to be 3 and this is 4 so
we have 4 over 3 and cubed plus 2 all
right so you with me so far
so now we're going to do is we're going
to distribute the 4 and we're going to
split these up into like individual
fractions okay so this is going to be 8
and cubed divided by 3 n cubed n cubes
are going to cancel and we get 8/3 okay
over here we get 12 n squared divided by
3 n cubed that's going to give you four
over N and if we distribute
for Harriet for n over three n cubed
which is going to give us one for over
three and squared okay plus two now the
two and eight thirds we can combine
that's going to be fourteen thirds plus
four over N plus four over three and
squared ok now basically it depends on
what n is right so if you have ten
rectangles then you're gonna end is
going to be ten if you have a hundred
rectangles and it's going to be a
hundred but what we're going to do now
is we're going to take the limit as n
approaches infinity so meaning as these
rectangles get thinner and thinner and
there's more and more of them so you can
see like okay kind of visualize this
here more and more of these rectangles
you can see right now I'm it's a little
bit of an over approximation say like
that but as n goes to infinity these are
rectangles are gonna get thinner and
thinner and what happens is this is
going to go to zero and this term is
going to go to zero because you're
dividing by N squared it's a cease large
and large that's going to go to zero so
we're really just left with fourteen
thirds so this is the exact area
underneath this parabola between zero
and two so I hope you enjoyed this video
I hope you learned some tips and some
techniques go ahead and subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon